alors mon loulou ça va hein
alors viens tous les jeudis adrien
coller un jeune ville provient de 24 ans
handicapée du côté gauche son rang dans
les écuries du château à plaisir pour
monter à cheval
une passion qu'il s'est découverte
depuis un an suite à une première
expérience c'est un ensemble et on va
dire des valeurs à la proche avec
l'animal en général mais je vais pas que
mon cheval à l'heure actuelle l'animal
en général puis avait l'esprit d'équipé
qui peut qu'on peut retrouver dans ce
sport là même si on pourrait croire que
c'est un sport un point d'y vivre sa
passion s'est rapidement traduite par
des résultats en compétition adrien est
devenu l'un des meilleurs cavaliers
handisport du département en l'espace de
quelques mois quand la vie tous les
jours est un combat permanent
les sacrifices et les efforts qu'il faut
fournir dans le sport de compétition
et bien finalement pour pour un individu
comme adrien masset une formalité
des résultats qu'il doit en grande
partie à son cheval zénith l'animal
adopté dès son arrivée au club depuis
les deux compétiteurs sont inséparables
c'est une relation très fusionnelle dès
que c'est un cheval dès qu'ils me voient
ils bas il sort la tête de son box où
dès qu'il entend la voiture arrivait par
ace tourner
il sait que c'est moi qui arrive donc
après l'expliqué réellement je sais pas
c'est vraiment un sentiment aujourd'hui
adrien n'a qu'un seul objectif en tête
avec son entraîneur qui le suit depuis
un an viser les jeux olympiques de 2024
à paris en tant qu'athlète handisport je
m'entraîne pour ça de base j'ai dès que
je monte à cheval je me dis allez adrien
fait l'effort dans peu de temps il ya
sans doute les yo qui sont à la porte
en attendant cette grosse échéance de
2024 adrien devra remporter encore
quelques compétitions avec son cheval
zénith pour rêver à toujours plus haut